Adidas CEO Kanye West did a mean
anti-semitic remarks this is a reuter
story ad Adidas CEO Bjorn golden
defended Kanye West stating I don't
think he meant that he said and I don't
think he's a bad person regarding y
anti-semitic remarks that led to the
termination of their Yeezy collaboration
gon acknowledged that he has made
statements that weren't that good and
praised him as one of the most creative
people in the world both in music and
what I will call Street culture didas
maintained its decision to end a
partnership with e with a spokesperson
confirming uh in affirming ending the
partnership was appropriate you think
there's going to be a comeback of Y
coming to Adidas what do you think when
you hear this story I think the whole
thing was a setup I think it was planned
I think yay is a genius and uh based on
my interview with him the way he was
talking to us before the show is nothing
like his public Persona he was calm
rational completely Lucid having a real
conversation he he was acting like this
he was like what do you think about if I
were to do X Y and Z right what's what's
what going on with Mike Pence how do
they feel about him that's how he was
talking yeah camera turns on yo man I'm
telling you got the guy in these Banks
and I was like what the just happened
and then he had a private jet waiting
for him after the show ended and I don't
know about you guys but I don't know how
you book a private jet in a couple hours
oh wow that's right oh wow if you guys
flying private jets you know you got to
Charter these things in advance they got
to get ground Crews when the ground crew
is
notified stopped it's a real
headache so I just go Southwest yeah I
get but you can buy the pre-board so
stressed that you know now I got to be
honest it's it's it's flying commercial
is a nightmare they United took me off
of my first class ticket and rebooked me
without telling me at 400 in the morning
onto a uh a seat all the way in the back
economy minus whatever it's called that
that thing where you're not allow to
have a carry on and I was like bro I
paid $1,000 for this flight cuz we had
to we had to you know we're going to
this trip and I was coming home and then
they were like too bad take the flight
or stay and I'm like what am I supposed
to do but anyway so yes so so you were
saying Tim about so so he's on the I'm
curious of where the setup is cuz if
he's on camera off camera speaking one
certain way all on cameras on like
almost some MK
Ultra yeah and then and then I I get the
point that you were making like and Pat
knows this like trying to get a freaking
it's a system they got to get people's
names they got to pre-board pre-check
you and do all that stuff so you're
saying like set up in what sense so uh
Shane Cashman one of our writers is a
huge yay fan and he talks he wrote this
article about how yay has these periods
where he shocks the world in an
offensive way and then leaves for a
little bit then has a major comeback
it's like a PR strategy or something
that affect MH he comes out and he says
all these things he agrees to come on
our show before the show while we're
talking totally lucid and calm he says I
have no reason to be on a show like this
and I said you're completely right I was
like you know why are you here like you
don't get more famous you want to come
come on my show I appreciate it and he's
like well these guys told me I should do
it but he's like what I'm really
interested in is you telling me how I
become president and I said ballot
harvesting he was like ballot harvesting
I'm like I said you want to know how the
Democrats won they don't win by by
convincing people they win by getting
more votes and you get more votes if
you're ballot harvesting he goes ballot
harvesting he writes it down he goes I
got what I needed shut up not kidding
show starts and all of a sudden he goes
from this calm Lucid guy leave to yo man
you I'm gon get a PJ if you keep talking
like that and then he gets up and he
walks out and I'm like is he he's
smiling he goes downstairs he thanks
everybody shakes hands he tells my
writer you want to come with me back to
LA and and and work with on some stuff
plane was waiting for him I I I called
our our charter company and I said did
you give him like did you give him a
plane like what happened and they were
like no no no no and I'm like Frederick
Municipal has a private jet I think it
was like a gulf stream or something
waiting for yay and I'm he can leave I'm
not I'm not mad about that but how did
he get a PJ in an hour and she and my my
broker but the charter lady she's like
that's not possible wow so the plane
knew the yes and then people are like
why would he do that because he got the
front page of every newspaper by walking
out on the show I see that if he doesn't
interview on like okay timcast IRL is a
big show I get it we we we typically
have like some of the highest live
numbers I think we're the biggest live
show consistently every night on YouTube
but we're nowh I don't beat you you're
sure I don't beat you you don't beat us
I'm kidding oh I don't know I'm kidding
but like we're not the biggest show in
the world or anything like that you know
in terms of podcast we do well so people
are like why would he Co on your show
and I'm like doing an interview with me
gets him nothing he does the interview
there are some clips people roll their
eyes storming off interview is hot press
for all the tabloids big time that was
your I think the important question is
what colors your PJ Jimmy his pajamas or
his private jet everybody's wondering
like P PJ why was he is his PJ and
didn't he just trademark yesterday he
trademarked 25 names uh for use ye WS
Kanye did that which is sounds like yeus
and Jew I don't know what he's did you
see that is trademark y wow but I want I
want to give some context too because uh
I'm you guys have flown on private jets
right yeah one well Jimmy multiple
obiously but what people need to
understand is it it's it's not as people
assume you have to have a multi-million
dollar jet it's not some private jets
only cost a couple hundred grand no no
joke if you if you look up on these
websites you can find a lot of the Jets
that they Charter and they fly are from
1980 and they're like $200,000 to buy
I'm not saying people have 200 Grand but
it's not $10 million like you see these
CEOs on Gulf streams chartering a
private jet can be $6,000 $8,000 if
you've got eight or8 to 12 people and
you're trying to fly last minute for
work it could actually be cheaper than
flying commercial if you're if you're
working in a corporation what kind of
plane is this is this the kind of plane
that's crashed 68,000 tur turbo
props turbo props you want to go Tim Tim
back to your master plan from Kanye okay
that was his master plan for your show I
I mean this all speculation but it seems
pretty accurate I I just from your
opinion because you've he did this on
your show but it was part of a bigger
master plan what's his overall master
plan to get in the headlines all right
because so one can argue all right I'm
gonna run up on stage and I'm gonna tell
Taylor Swift that it should have been
Beyonce all right cool you
know doesn't care about black people
Mike Myer George okay awesome hey I'm
gonna marry Kim K I'm gonna get all I'm
gonna all the women of the world are
gonna my next album okay amazing all
right I'm gonna team up with J Jay-Z
Watch the Throne no Mar Kim K wasn't a
stunt he loved that woman obviously but
there was some stuff go involved there
then all right I'm going to go see U uh
Donald Trump with Jim Brown I'm going to
do all that walk me through Let Me Go
full Pro Hitler
anti-jew death Con 3 walk me through the
marketing strategy for that you I mean I
can only speculate but he's a
billionaire he's done not anymore yeah
but what does it really mean to be a
billionaire I like if you're talking
about paper value and like shoe deals
are worth a couple hundred million
dollars the dude wants for nothing I I
you look at some of these people they
get to that point where they're bored I
had a buddy of mine became a millionaire
at 16 I didn't meet him when we were 16
I met him when we were in our late 20s
and he told me that for most
people at least that he knows especially
in the tech sector they have an
existential crisis once they get to that
level of money so like for him he's like
this young guy he comes up with his idea
they start building this thing and then
all of a sudden he's got millions of
dollars and he's sitting there staring
at the all like what do I do all my
friends are at work I'm not I don't have
to do anything now I I sold out there's
no company anymore I don't need anything
and it was like a switch flip where they
he had an existential crisis and he says
a bunch of my friends experienced this
so you look at someone like yay and I'm
like he's bored he's bored and it's
funny and there's nothing you can do
about it because he's more powerful than
you it makes him laugh he wants to see
what'll happen he wants to challenge
preconceived notions he wants to break
people out of what he perceives as the
Matrix he made a point that a lot of
people praised when he said that he
loved Hitler
and people were shocked by it and I
think the point he was trying to make
was as a Christian he loves everyone
even the most evil people he wants
salvation for them but he also knows
that by saying something so shocking you
would freak out and he's trying to prove
that point that you don't love people
and I'm like I can understand why nobody
likes Hitler dude are you crazy but he's
trying to make a point I could only
speculate he wants to shock you it's
punk rock I mean I'm not saying it's a
good thing but what was it Sid Vicious
War a swastika it's it's like why did he
do that Jimmy why you smiling you got
this big smile jimmmy knows what's going
Jim's like listen I've been a
billionaire since 6 years old Jimmy is
there anything you'd like to say about
the Jews right now well I remember when
this happened the my friend called me
goes hey did you hear the Jews cancel
Kanye and I was like did they catch him
shipping arms to Nazis in
Ukraine and they said no he just said
some stuff and I'm like oh that's bad
too yeah simp did did Jews cancel Kanye
or did he actually cancel himself
because it sounds like this was part of
he uncancelled but yeah is that happen
he's back yeah but and Tim you made a
point earlier like if he got cancelled
for saying those words the Canadian
Parliament had an actual Nazi on the
goddamn floor they should have cancelled
the Canadian they shut down Canada are
you freaking kidding me and I get it
words hurt but for that moment to go
down and then what they do they just
fire the the speaker of the house just
steps down you had a a Nazi that
actually killed Jews that that is absurd
Hitler Nazi a Hitler Nazi not a regular
na the original the
OG so if you like this clip and you want
to watch another one click right here
and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here